un geste peut attendre vu en ces lieux
d'histoire mais dans le château de
breteuil aussi le gel hydroalcoolique et
les masques sont primordiaux pour la
visite
les équipes ont aussi revu leur
fonctionnement nous limitons les départs
à 10 personnes et des gens évoluent
librement dans le parcours du château ce
qui est nouveau ce sont des pupitres
dans toutes les pièces pour indiquer les
donnait les explications les
commentaires de la scène et des objets
d'art que les gens peuvent voir dans
cette pièce le château a rouvert ses
grilles le 15 mai dernier les visiteurs
étaient au rendez vous la fréquentation
ressembler à celle d'un mois de juin
normal mille visiteurs ont foulé les
pelouses du domaine le dimanche 17 mai
montre une semaine dans les vallées et
on a vu qu'ils avaient beaucoup de
châteaux
on me posait deux trois questions nous y
était un joueur donc
nous voici ça fait déjà maintenant deux
mois qu'on est confiné à paris donc
c'est effectivement assez compliqué à
vivre
donc on a eu le début du déconfinement
balle et c'est de faire un petit
week-end elle les deux mois de fermeture
ont bien sûr eu un impact financier des
salariés sont encore en chômage partiel
les mariages ne pourrait pas reprendre
avant le 18 juillet
avril mai juin sont les gros mois pour
nous puisque nous avons entre autres
toutes les sorties scolaires de fin
d'année donc depuis le 15 mars
plus aucun groupe scolaire n'est venu et
ne reviendra pas avant septembre
ces mois de fermeture vont représenter
environ le tiers du chiffre d'affaires
annuel
les équipes ont mis à profit le
confinement pour entretenir le site
après une année 2010 neuf records en
terme de fréquentation
le château de breteuil prend son mal en
patience